look at Goldie Hawn walking around
goldie city
get up out there chick come on get up
after Chester ain't nobody gonna be
looking at me while they stand today
cooter she is oh by the way I've been
asked to issue a reminder to the people
here in the audience please remember to
behave responsibly at the party's after
the show apparently last year some
producer got so drunk he left her with a
woman his own age
the next award good are you having a
good time
roberta you getting my jokes man you
understanding my jokes you not
understand it another thing I'm saying
are you
you think I'm funny glad sir
anyway the next award is for sound
effects editing and to present it a
young man who's been making an awful lot
of noise in the last couple of years the
lethally comic Chris Rock
Thank You Oprah thank you No
I say it would love I love you I love
you I love you okay I'm out here look at
this crowd it's like the million white
man March here today I'm loving it I'm
loving it's a big controversial night
the Kazan thing I saw DeNiro backstage
you better get Kazan away from De Niro
because you know he hates rats now we're
here hey you can't do that man now
somebody has a death wish if they wanted
me to come up here actually there's no
reason to be nervous because my category
is sound effects editing and Who am I
gonna offend a Foley artist I mean come
on snap now some of you might be
wondering what exactly is sound effects
editing is what sound effects editing if
President Clinton had sound effects
editing when he said I did not sleep
with that woman he could have went back
and said cut that out so here we go now
here are the three films nominated this
year for sound effects editing George
waters the second for Armageddon
David McCoy ler for the Masters all
right Gary Rydstrom and Richard Holmes
the Saving Private Ryan and the Oscar
for sound effects editor editing goes to
Jerry Rice Fuhrman Richard - seven
flatline
this is the sixth Academy Award for
Garry Rydstrom he previously shared an
Oscar with Richard him thus for Jurassic
Park
this is a great film it was a wonderful
opportunity for sound and we took it
it is our benchmark thank you most of
all the Steven Spielberg I can't think
of a greater compliment for a director
then you inspire people to do their best
work and that was certainly true of the
people up to Skywalker Sound especially
the amazing sound effects that is Ethan
van Duren Terry Acton Franco and like
Aaron Wilson Larry outfield and my
fabulous assistants Lisa Chino and Andre
Finley thanks to the indispensable
Shannon Mills thanks to paramount
DreamWorks and especially Marty Cohen
thanks for a great Foley team Dennie
Thorpe and Jana Vance personal thanks to
my family my mom and dad and thanks to
Cindy my beautiful trophy wife